Think about the two people you can imagine
who'd be least likely to be baking cookies together.
It's John Travolta and Tommy Lee.
Yeah, huh.
The New York Post Reports,
apparently they love trading baking recipe.
Tommy Lee posted a video on TikTok
showing his pal, John, texting him one Wednesday night,
asking for his killer peanut butter chocolate chip recipe.
And later John shared a pic of his cookies in the oven,
calling himself a regular Johnny Crocker.
And we're in luck because guess what?
We've got some of Tommy Lee's special recipes right here.
Oh my gosh.
This is the actual peanut butter cookie recipe
and he does it with chocolate chips in it.
I heard John Travolta also drinks it with lemonade.
I feel like this is wrong on many levels,
but I'm gonna try it.
(audience laughs)
Boy, there's a little salt.
Okay, yeah, ooh, Tommy Lee.
(audience laughs)
Drew, you cannot tell me
that's not a great peanut butter cookie.
No, it is.
(upbeat music)
♪ Oh oh oh oh ♪